antenne de 20h le journal de la
rédaction
henri sannier bonsoir et merci d'être
fidèle au journal d'antenne de à la une
ce soir une nouvelle fois la tourmente
sur les marchés monétaires le dollar est
au plus bas sur les places européennes
et à new york paris et bonn réaffirment
leur coopération
à new york le secrétaire au trésor
monsieur baker est catégorique la baisse
du dollar est préférable à une récession
réactions et explications dans quelques
instants
non
charles hernu persiste je n'ai jamais
donné d'ordre pour l'exportation d'armes
vers l'iran
aujourd'hui le juge en appel à la cour
de cassation pour entendre l'homme clé
de la sphère ex collaborateur de
l'ancien mini grâce à une caméra de
surveillance les images d'une opération
commando à l' usine renault d'errani le
26 octobre du matériel bloqués par une
grève sortira par la voie des airs
la révolution de gorbatchev en librairie
le 19 novembre pérestroïka est déjà un
best-seller avant sa sortie mondiale
flammarion acquis les droits d'un livre
écrit à l'américaine la mémoire du
cinéma perd l'une de ses têtes georges
franju est mort cette nuit à l'âge de 76
ans georges franju co fondateur de la
cinémathèque poète du fantastique et
père de fantômas au grand écran une
journée supplémentaire de détention pour
marcel carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
new york où l'exploit trois jours après
ils étaient 22 milles dimanche au départ
du traditionnel marathon de new york
l'un d'entre eux n'est arrivé
qu'aujourd'hui au terme d'une course pas
tout à fait comme les autres
l'homme que vous allez voir nous donne à
tous une belle leçon de courage
paul nahon trois jours 9 heures 56
minutes 38 secondes
bob wiland a battu son propre record de
l'année dernière de 16 heures hier soir
à son arrivée à central park une partie
de la ville s'était arrêté pour voir
passer ce marathonien de tous les
courages bob wiland a perdu ses deux
jambes au vietnam en 1969 au nord ouest
de saigon depuis il couvre pour toutes
les causes celles des anciens du vietnam
ou de la faim dans le monde
il a traversé l'amérique de cette façon
d'est en ouest où trois ans et quatre
jours ci sa performance physique est
extraordinaire ne croyez pas que le
temps qu'il réalise lui soit indifférent
il court pour gagner sur lui-même et
améliorer ses records
on m'avait donné pour mort à l'arrivée à
l'hôpital
je suis en vie aujourd'hui je suis
descendu de ma chaise roulante et
j'étais moi même surpris de la vitesse à
laquelle j'ai pu marcher comme tous les
grands champions bob wiland adroit sont
ralentis mais il pense déjà au prochain
marathon son marathon celui de 88
il va s'entraîner très dur pour encore
améliorer son temps 42 km en trois jours
9h56 puis 38 secondes
chapeau monsieur wiland
en france toujours la sphère lüscher
après les rebondissements enregistré
hier charles hernu parle il parle au
micro d'antenne de l'image et le ton
change et l'homme à gaza et qui
visiblement en maîtriser assez mal son
discours compte un peu plus de recul
aujourd'hui et en us explique dans un
contexte difficile mais son personnage
est plus que jamais sur la sellette à
lyon reportage de bernard pradines haut
dans cette mise en cause de charles
hernu la presse le net il va pas de main
morte pour le progrès charles hernu
explose pour lyon libération voilà une
photo de l'ancien ministre de la défense
avec un revolver à la main
quant à la presse parisienne numéro
spécial de l'événement elle se demande
si hernu est devenu fou le maire de
villeurbanne après s'être fâché tout
rouge hier contre les journalistes
étaient aujourd'hui plus serein entouré
de ses collaborateurs
il rappelle qu'il n'est pas
officiellement mise en cause et minimise
la faire je reste un homme qui décide et
le battre si mon honneur était menacé il
l'est pas les français peuvent
légitimement se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi des ventes d'armes et
aurait échappé à la connaissance du
ministère de la défense et à plus forte
raison de ceux du ministre j'ai déjà
répondu à cette question
j'ai répondu il ya un an quand pour la
première fois un hebdomadaire
on a parlé j'ai répondu une seconde fois
il ya six mois je n'ai jamais donné
d'ordre d'exportation d'un fermier cet
après midi toujours dans la sphère
lüscher le juge legrand a demandé la
saisine de la chambre criminelle de la
cour d'assises acide d'accusation
pourquoi cette démarche et bien tout
simplement parce que dans la sphère
lüscher certaines personnes bénéficient
d'un statut protégé entre guillemets ces
personnes ne peuvent être entendus que
par une juridiction compétente désigné
par la cour de cassation
cette ordonnance a été rendue nécessaire
en raison de la mise en cause de jean
françois dubost l'ancien homme fort du
cabinet de charles hernu actuellement
maître de requêtes au conseil d'état
à noter également aujourd'hui une
première réaction de françois diaz diaz
l'ami de longue date de charles hernu
suspecté d'avoir reçu deux ou trois
millions de
centime de 3 millions de francs de la
part de la société du cher françois diaz
rejette en bloc toutes les accusations
olivier lerner voici l'un des hommes
clés de la sphère du cher françois diaz
militaires proches de charles hernu qui
jusqu'à ce jour était resté dans l'ombre
de l'ancien ministre de la défense dans
le rapport barba françois diaz dénoncé
par daniel dewavrin pdg de l'alu cher
est accusé d'avoir touché en tant
qu'intermédiaire entre 2 millions et
demi et 3 millions de francs de
commissions sur les ventes d'armes à
l'iran
ce que je tiens vous dire du fond du
coeur en toute sincérité
c'est que je suis étranger à tout cela
monsieur vraiment étranger à tout cela
on ne peut pas accabler un homme je suis
abasourdi vous souhaitez la lumière sur
la cchg mon avocat font leur métier je
vois là mais l'instruction en cours et
nous irons aussi longtemps aussi souvent
que nécessaire chez juge d'instruction
c'est tout pour le moment c'est beau
temps a pris contact avec vous pas
encore je suis gentil
françois dire assez dur désormais au
premier rang des inculpés potentiel avec
jean françois dubost proche
collaborateur de charles hernu au
ministère de la défense et daniel
dewavrin
le pdg de la vie chère françois diaz
l'organisateur du financement de la
campagne des municipales de charles
hernu en 83 devra dire devant le juge si
oui ou non une partie de ces commissions
ont été versées au parti socialiste
au delà des réactions de ceux qui sont
présentés comme les personnages clés de
cette affaire les réflexions vont bon
train aujourd'hui la petite phrase d'un
confrère du monde résume assez bien
d'ailleurs la situation je cite bombardé
à l'aube 855 depuis le début de la
semaine le paysage politique
s'apparentera peut-être un jour un champ
de ruines en dehors de cette image
beaucoup se demandent ce soir s'il a
sonné pas lancées contre l'elysée
rachid arhab les obus de la sphère
lüscher atteindront il les lisait donc
le président de la république
brienne permet de lire pour l'instant
mais dans la classe politique à droite
comme à gauche des voix s'élèvent pour
demander à françois mitterrand de parler
je fais hautement confiance au président
de la république dans cette phase pré
présidentielle où le gouvernement
cherche à se défausser d'un certain
nombre de ses responsabilités
économiques et sociales
je lui fais confiance pour établir
clairement la réalité point nous en
sommes
la plénitude de la lumière sur la
conduite des affaires de l'état dans une
affaire d'état ne peut venir que du
sommet de l'état jean le camus et s'est
exprimé après l'audition d'andré giron
par la commission de la défense
nationale une réunion à huis clos à
l'issue de laquelle en déclaré côté rpr
que le ministre avait contribuer à
décrisper puis la sphère important des
crispations c'est aussi ce que
souhaiterait apparemment jacques chirac
le premier ministre alors vous bd vauban
four malheureusement et c'est un des
points faibles
il ya notamment des périodes c'est la
classe
si l'on en croit nos confrères du nouvel
observateur les différents scandales met
la classe politique en danger un sondage
sofres nouvel obs nous apprend que pour
56% des français
les hommes politiques sont surtout
soucieux de leurs intérêts personnels
54% des personnes interrogées pensent
que la classe politique ne tient pas
compte de l'opinion française
enfin vous allez le voir la gauche et la
droite sont renvoyés dos à dos pour 63%
des personnes interrogées
on n'est pas plus honnêtes à gauche qu'à
droite bref les français ont la dent
dure pour les politiques les élus peut
incontestablement le prix des affaires
tempête sur le monde politique les gros
nuages sur les marchés monétaires le
dollar est au plus bas sur les
différentes places 5 francs 68,50 est
nettement en dessous d'un marc 70
aujourd'hui à new york
apparemment la décision des états unis
accroît considérablement la tourmente
dans ce concert d'incertitude la petite
phrase de james baker le secrétaire
américain au trésor a fait l'effet d'une
bombe
james baker a notamment déclaré que la
baisse du dollar était préférable à la
récession l'ambiance à washington avec
jacques à bouchard dix jours de
discussions serrées de marchandage au
capital de washington est toujours pas
de résultats la maison blanche et les
élus du congrès s'affrontent sans
pouvoir résoudre le casse-tête de
l'énorme déficit
budgétaire un compromis se dessine
pourtant sur le chiffre de 24 milliards
de dollars d'économies pour combler au
moins en partie le gouffre notoirement
insuffisant déclarent les financiers
alors que wall street
encore sous le choc du lundi noir a les
yeux braqués sur washington
le message des boursiers au politique
est claire faites vite quelque chose ou
alors nous plongeons robert soleau
lauréat du nobel d'économie 87
comme son illustre collègue john
galbraith pour tes récemment des
jugement très sévère sur la politique
économique et financière de
l'administration régal le président
s'efforce sans vraiment convaincre de
donner l'impression qu'il y a toujours
fermement la barre à paris vives
réactions d'edouard balladur cet après
midi le ministre de l'économie et des
finances s'est félicité ouvertement de
la coopération monétaire qui s'instaure
avec les allemands concrètement paris
augmente ses taux à court terme alors
que bonn les révise à la baisse
bref les autorités monétaires françaises
et allemandes s'associent et associent
leurs efforts pour promouvoir la
stabilité des marchés financiers
dans l'esprit des accords du louvre
notre objectif est clair il faut
maintenir la stabilité monétaire
dans le cadre du système monétaire
européen
notre objectif est également clair il
faut maintenir les acquis de notre
politique de redressement financier
je voudrais mettre en garde chacun
contre un pessimisme exagéré
certes nous connaissons des difficultés
nous devons tout faire et c'est le
devoir du gouvernement pour que ces
difficultés n'ait pas de conséquences
sérieuses sur la poursuite de notre
redressement
l'heure n'est pas ni au catastrophisme
ni au pessimisme
l'heure n'est pas au changement de cap
de la politique économique
l'heure est à la lucidité au courage et
à la volonté on est derrière tout ça
finisse à sienne ya quand même l'ombre
d'un réaménagement qui se profile un
jour a pour l'instant il n'en est plus
question c'est justement pour couper
court à toutes les rumeurs qui
circulaient depuis plusieurs jours selon
lesquelles on allait droit à un
réaménagement monétaire peut être ce
week-end que paris est bonne on te fait
ont pris ce tournant et ont décidé ce
qui a été décidé cet après midi d'un
côté donc bonne baisse ses taux
d'intérêt parise augmente bonne baisse
des taux d'intérêt malgré un indice
des prix médiocre en allemagne pour les
allemands 0 2%
dos au mois d'octobre donc pour
l'instant il n'est plus question du tout
de réaménagement monétaire du mois en
europe
ou alors le crédit va être plus cher
pour nous non non ce sont les ce sont
les taux à court terme
ils ont donc par conséquent les taux à
long terme ceux des investissements se
dit prêt par exemple à la construction
ne devrait pas bouger
une bonne nouvelle la balle est plus que
jamais dans le camp des américains si
j'ai bien compris
plus que jamais dans le camp les
américaines puisque aujourd'hui les
européens notamment les allemands et
français ont fait un geste de bonne
volonté ils ont montré leur ferme
volonté de se défendre contre la chute
du dollar qui se poursuit ce soir à new
york maintenant aux américains de
s'entendait de faire des propositions
merci à tahiti retour au calme après les
émeutes du 23 octobre dernier 53
personnes ont été écrouées et dans
l'immédiat peu d'élément nouveau si ce
n'est que l'un des principaux syndicats
de polynésie française a appelé le
gouvernement local à ouvrir le dialogue
sur les problèmes sociaux du territoire
ce soir deuxième volet de notre enquête
à tahiti les jeunes face à la situation
ambiante les jeunes qui représentent 50
% de la population ce n'est pas rien
sont confrontés au chômage et surtout à
la délinquance pour eux comme pour
beaucoup la douceur de vivre et parfois
de l'histoire ancienne carte haïti
présente aujourd'hui les symptômes d'une
société malade dominique tierces
il pas parfois jouer en ligue 1 mais qu
anthony nos christian raphaël
ils ont tous entre 15 et 25 ils
appartiennent à la même dans de la bande
de l'emi un quartier populaire à 10km de
papeete cela fait longtemps qu'ils ne
vont plus à l'école
ils sont sans travail et leur vie c'est
le bord de la route on passe notre temps
tous les jours comme ça allez voir les
copains en marche de d'en bas d'en haut
toujours comme ça on écoute de la
musique vous pas un peu en jour au cap à
peine plus âgés bruno vit dans un autre
monde
il est chef d'entreprise quarante cinq
personnes sous ses ordres il dirige une
usine agroalimentaire dans la famille
van comme chez de nombreux chinois
tahiti le business c'est une tradition
études coûteuses aux états unis puis
retour dans ce qu'il considère son pays
j'ai vécu dans une vraie oui avec le
détail on faisait la bicicleta il est
allé jouer au football avec des
tahitiennes
le chinois est pas le cas ici le
tahitien
l'acceptent donc polynésiens belle et où
on retrouve sur la route
depuis l'eau mètres plus bas arpentez
leur territoire c'est à peu près leur
seule occupation tous les jours la bonne
façon
c'est comme ça
au menu youlou une sorte de patate douce
et trois boîtes de cambi
8 10 12 heures de travail par jour bruno
ne compte pas il est disponible s'il le
faut à toutes heures dans la communauté
chinoise ils incarnent le dynamisme la
réussite celle que bien peu de tahitiens
peuvent afficher
est-ce que parfois vous vous dites que
la communauté chinoise ici va avoir des
problèmes plus tard avec les tahitiens
il ya à prendre et à 6 à la rigolade
vendredi le fera ni le pourquoi c'est
comme et à éviter le chinois le chinois
qui dit aux tahitiens le canal disant
que c'est si amical c'était amical à
didier un crash gracia ce serait plutôt
metropolit a vu les siens 50 % de la
population a ici moins de 20 ans aucune
statistique officielle fait état du taux
de chômage chez les jeunes
on estime les diplômés universitaires
tahitien à quelques dizaines seulement
et d'ailleurs l'école est obligatoire
que jusqu'à 14 ans
depuis mai
voyons rapidement les télégrammes de
l'étranger ensuite en compagnie de
georges bortoli nous vous dirons tout
sur ce livre le livre de mikhaïl
gorbatchev qui sort dans quelques jours
c'est officiel que sport winnberg heures
démissionne de ses fonctions de
secrétaire américain à la défense le
président reagan a rendu hommage à celui
qui a été son ministre pendant 700 avant
de présenter son successeur frank
carlucci le conseiller de la maison
blanche aux questions de sécurité
lui-même remplacé par le général powell
premier noir à occuper ce poste
beyrouth ville morte la grève générale
et illimitée est largement suivie au
liban
le mouvement lancé par la confédération
des travailleurs libanais entend réagir
contre l'enlisement du pays dans la
crise économique
dans la capitale les commerces restent
fermés tandis que les rues chose
inhabituelle sont quasiment désert
afrique du sud remise en liberté d'un
des dirigeants historiques de la haine
c'est le congrès national africain joe
van beck qui 77 ans avait été condamné à
vie en 1964 en même temps que nelson
mandela pretoria annonce en outre qu'un
nombre considérable de prisonniers
politiques de toutes races seront
libérés prochainement
les armes saisies à bord de l'ex ou
n'était sans doute également destinée à
une attaque de grande envergure contre
la prison de maze à belfast où 300
membres de l'ira sont actuellement
emprisonnés
la police irlandaise semble en être
persuadé tandis qu'à londres le foreign
office accrédite la thèse de l'origine
libyenne de la cargaison du bateau
le livre de michael gorbatchev intitulé
pérestroïka un nouveau monde d'un
nouveau mode plutôt de pensée pour notre
pays et pour le monde sera disponible
dans quelques jours une opération
médiatique sans précédent puisque le
livre sortira pratiquement le même jour
dans 19 pays du monde
ce qui est étonnant c'est que michael
gorbatchev a accepté 50% des changements
rédactionnelle proposé par son éditeur
américain michael bay 6 michael bay ci
se trouve avoir un manuscrit en main ou
début septembre
un manuscrit qui est déjà traduit en
anglais qui a une première traduction
qui est fait par les soviétiques et
qu'il traduction anglaise il passe
plusieurs jours dans un hôtel on dit à
leningrad en ligne directe avec
gorbatchev qui est à l'époque en crimée
et un interprète il fait là ce qu'on
appelle de l'éditing c'est à dire qu'il
propose un certain nombre de corrections
devraient dans le livre c'est tout à
fait amusant et intéressant parce que tu
ne pars dans dans la dédicace aux
lecteurs si je puis dire
il y a effectivement très explicitement
dit que ce livre est fait à la demande
d'un éditeur américain et une fois dans
le livre du liana demande de miss
glitter je pensais qu ici fallait donner
quelques exemples est un peu plus vive a
enfin il ya même dans le dans le livre
des traces si vous voulez c'est l'acteur
américain est orienté plus ou moins avec
leurs lectures vous avez orienté restons
calme quand même parce que je ne pense
pas qu'on puisse tellement orientée une
cale gorbatchev sur ce qu'il avait fait
rires mais sur le style même du bouquin
oui semble-t-il sur les styles du livory
georges bortoli pérestroïka c'est
vraiment la bible de l'air gorbatchev
oui je t aime que monsieur gorbatchev a
inventé car il est cet affairisme et
qu'il a imposées au fond ça correspond
un tout petit peu à ce que l'église
catholique appelée ladja de la main au
moment de vatican 2 c'est la mise à jour
du marché
alors l'objectif je suppose est de
toucher un maximum de lecteurs de les
toucher à défaut de convaincre
oui oui c'est un nouveau message
monsieur papa de chasse ont fait passer
tout le temps des messages par la
télévision la radio et c'est à la
séparent lire pour persuader essayer de
persuader que premièrement sa politique
internationale notamment ceux politique
de désarmement c'est la meilleure
possible et deuxièmement que sa
politique de réformes l'urss c'est aussi
la meilleure possible marsalis très
sérieux on avait tout à l'heure mais il
ya quand même quelques anecdotes à
l'intérieur oui c'est sérieux c'est
surtout sérieux parce qu'un secrétaire
général soviétique ça d'abord d'abord
être un théoricien à intéresser les
marques sydney spa c'est un ministre dit
qu'il faut porter mais il ya tout de
même quelques anecdotes pas énormément
par exemple il cite deux lettres qu'il
dit avoir reçu récemment qu'ils nous
parlent d'ailleurs très soigneusement
sélectionnés lune et d'un ouvrier qui
lui écrit alors maintenant vous savez
mon fils m'appelle à grands cris quand
vous parlez à la télévision et pourtant
il accepte en effet puis la seconde
c'est d'un catholique que lituaniens qui
lui écrit qu'il eut écrit il faut que
vous sachiez que tous les dimanches je
suis à l'église de 9 heures à 13 heures
et que tous les dimanches je prie pour
vous et votre famille alors ça c'est bon
c'est quelque peu anecdotique 1 on l'a
bien compris sur le fond le message est
clair l'urss continue dans la voie
socialiste
absolument il écrit également monsieur
gorbatchev il n'est pas question de nous
faire essayer un costume coupé pour
d'autres ça veut dire que l'économie va
rester centralisée planifier et diriger
et cetera mais qui va exiger essayé
d'exiger des gens qui travaillent plus
et mieux au fond disons que c'est le
changement des changements mais dans la
continuité
merci genre social on reparle d'une
affaire qui avait fait beaucoup de bruit
récemment à la régie renault il ya
quinze jours à eragny dans le val d'oise
la direction décidé de transférer par
hélicoptère jeudi par hélicoptère des
pièces de rechange une opération
commando
qualifiée de musclée par les syndicats
au moment précis où lesdits syndicats
occupent l usine aujourd'hui la cgt
les piquets de grève et rend public un
document vidéo très révélateur regarder
il est 17 heures en ce lundi 26 octobre
une caméra de surveillance finma
l'étrange ballet pour la première fois
en france on utilise la voie des airs
pour contourner les piquets de grève des
concessionnaires de la régie charge
caisse après caisse des tonnes de pièces
détachées l'opération héliportée est
minutieusement organisé trois
hélicoptères ont été affrétés une
soixantaine d'hommes mobilisés et la
cour de lusine transformé en véritable
héliport tout est prévu
à l'autre bout de lusine des
concessionnaires arrivés en renfort
tente de faire diversion en s'opposant
au piquet de grève
au total plusieurs tonnes de matériel
seront emportés par le commando
le cinéma une nouvelle fois en deuil
georges franju est mort hier soir à
l'âge de 75 ans réalisateur de judex en
1963 il a défendu le ferment le
fantastique et le surréalisme dans le
cinéma français georges bigot
cofondateur avec henri langlois de la
cinémathèque française franju était un
cinéaste original en dehors des modes un
fou de cinéma qui vouait aux pionniers
louis feuillade créateur de judex une
admiration sans bornes
son goût de la poésie de l'insolite du
fantastique l'ont conduit à réaliser des
films aussi différents que les yeux sans
visage avec edith scop et pierre
brasseur thérèse desqueyroux avec
emmanuelle riva et philippe noiret aussi
bien que thomas l'imposteur avec fabrice
où l'eau ou bien la faute de l'abbé
mouret l'après zola et les nuits rouges
encore un hommage à fantômas quel homme
visiblement à l'ordre
est un comportement anormal c'est normal
par contre le personnage m'inquiète
beaucoup plus à partir du moment où
ayant un aspect normal il se conduit
alors là on a également appris cet après
midi le décès de daniel gaubert l'épousé
de jean claude killy l'ancien champion
de ski danielle gobert avait renoncé au
cinéma en 1973 elle avait connu son
heure de gloire en 1959 dans régates de
san francisco un film de claude
autant-lara le sport jean mamère sport
synonyme de tennis en ce moment sur
antenne 2 et qui les diffusent beaucoup
de tennis il va diffuser encore ce soir
à partir de 22h10 dans les résultats de
cet après midi à noter la qualification
de scheepers un joueur issu des tours
qualificatifs qui a battu et c'est
logique soviétique volkov classée 191e
mondiale en trois sets 3-6 6-4 6-4
par contre la surprise est venue de
l'élimination de la tête de série numéro
1 miroslav mecir par kevin curran
l'américain messire était déjà mal en
point lors du premier tour face à forger
il est tombé cette fois ci au 2e tour
que rennes il faut le dire a très bien
joué et surtout très très bien volleyé
tout au long de la partie
n'hésitant pas à prendre
bon oui mais messire a lutté jusqu'au
bout et il s'est défendu sur toutes les
balles malheureusement cela n'a pas
suffi cet après midi face à un joueur
aussi agressif que kevin cure est en ce
moment que se passe-t-il alors que
rennes a donc réalisé un exploit ils
l'emportent finalement en deux sets 7-5
6-4 et il rencontrera peut-être nous en
demi-finale chinois se qualifie le soir
quand je vous propose justement alors
que l'on voit les deux joueurs qui serre
la main d'aller tout de suite en direct
à bercy où nous retrouvons le match qui
vient juste de commencer qui oppose
thomas schmid le tchécoslovaque numéro
39 mondiale à brad gilbert tu
l'américain numéro quatorzième numéro 14
mondial et thomas schmidt qui est au
service vient de remporter le premier
jeu la partie qui suivra opposera
yannick noah à l'iranien barani merci à
suivre donc ce soir sur antenne 2 je
vous donne rapidement les rapports du
quarté et du tiercé qui se courait cet
après-midi sur l'hippodrome de vincennes
dans le tiercé il fallait jouer le 6 le
11 et le neuf dans l'ordre exact 50 2069
rend dans un ordre différent 992 francs
le quarté 6 11 9 17 rapporte gros dans
un ordre exacte d'arrivée vous loyer de
9093 1942 francs et dans un ordre
différent 78000 28 francs 50 c'est ça
hein 6 11 9 17 rester avec nos gens je
sais que vous êtes un fan d'automobile
les voitures que nous allons vous
montrer défraie la chronique pour deux
raisons d'une part parce qu'elles ont
des lignes très futuriste vous allez le
voir de l'autre parce qu'elle fonctionne
grâce à des cellules photovoltaïques
philippe duez ambiance de course de
formule 1 au départ de darwin ou 23
véhicules vont tenter de traverser
l'australie
c'est à dire 3200 km grâce uniquement à
l'énergie solaire il utile de préciser
que les géants de l'automobile japonais
ou américains sont présents
cela montre bien que ce système de
propulsion est en train de sortir des
rêves parfois difficile à réaliser
ici on est déjà dans le concret du 21e
siècle
rien n'a été laissé au hasard ni les
matériaux ultra-légers ni les batteries
très performante pour arriver à rouler
sous le soleil ou dans les nuages après
200 kilomètres à l'heure
arrivée prévue samedi ou dimanche à
adelaïde
après une semaine de course ouais c'est
loin de chez nous mais ça pourrait
presque rouler en france en ce moment
alors nous avons pourquoi on chez henry
parce que nous avons un bel anticyclone
et c'est pourquoi nous avons surnommées
notre météo aujourd'hui le malabar du
milibach malabar et bien si
l'anticyclone qui est costaud qui est
plein de biscotos 1036 hectopascals
obili barre à lille en ce moment et 1034
à paris si vous avez un baromètre vous
tapotez dessus et vous verrez ce
baromètre est à la hausse
résultat demain et bien vous allez voir
sur la carte pro c'est même pas la peine
de la commenter et du sol et partout il
y aura du soleil par tous à partir de 10
heures en revanche on nous attarder
quand même sur les températures de
demain matin demain matin parce que pour
la première fois depuis bien longtemps
nous allons atteindre maintenant des
gelées extrêmement basses - elle voyait
c'est températures autour de -1 à -3
degrés dans l'est mais ce sont les
températures en ville en rase campagne
nous irons jusqu'à -5 degrés il en sera
de même - 2 - 3 en touraine
dans toutes ces régions et même un jour
parisienne pensez à vos plantes si vous
en avez dans la journée de demain bien
sûr le thermomètre va remonter vos
atteindront de températures beaucoup
plus sympathique à peu près les mêmes
qu'aujourd'hui avec un petit 9 degrés
dans l'est mais là parce qu'elle arrive
du diable vauvert
en revanche dans le sud-est dans le
sous-bois y ait 20 à 21 degrés demain et
bien elle nous fêterons les bertille et
le lez soleil se lèvera à 7h46 ce
touchera se couchera à 17h22 et
j'oubliais de vous dire qu'il fera moins
4 degrés à coin en moselle où il fera je
leur en quoi la gelée de coings avant de
rendre l'antenne regardez bien ces
images c'est le début d'une grande
chaîne pour combattre la myopathie une
maladie redoutable dont les causes sont
encore inconnues
cet après-midi les sapeurs-pompiers ont
entamé un tour de france pour récolter
les fonds des fonds qui seront mises à
disposition de tous ceux qui luttent
contre la myopathie
l'opération se déroulera les 4 et 5
décembre prochains sur antenne 2 26
heures d'antenne pour vous sensibiliser
téléthon c'est le nombre d'émissions
non-stop que nous vous proposons sera
l'histoire d'un coup de coeur de
l'équipe d'antenne 2 pour les malades
oublié
prochain rendez vous d'information 23h30
avec aubry et de l'air de menthe et les
matins dès 6h45 pour les lève tôt
philippe mestres proche de raymond barre
et députés sera l'invité des 4 vérités
de gérard morin excellente soirée sur
antenne 2 je vous retrouve demain 20h
bonsoir